Today Nate has 100 bananas.
He will eat two of them every day.
Is the number of bananas left on Nate,
the number of days that have passed?
I recommend that you pause the video
and think about it.
Interestingly here,
that it is not said the number of eaten bananas,
but wonders if the number of bananas left on Nate,
is directly proportional to the number of days that have passed.
Let's draw a small tray here to think
on that a little more.
Will do
3 columns.
In the first column
will be the number of days that have passed.
The number of days,
which have passed.
Here we have
the number of days that have passed.
In the middle column
I will write the number of bananas left on Nate.
Remaining
bananas.
And here I will make a relationship between the two.
To have a straightforward relationship,
the relationship between the two must be constant.
The remaining bananas.
I will split the second column of the first one.
The remaining bananas
divided by
the past days.
Let's think a little about this.
When it is one day,
how many bananas will they have left?
On the first day he will have eaten 2 bananas,
so there will be 98 remaining bananas.
What is the attitude of the other bananas to the past days?
Well this is 98 on 1, which will be 98.
All right.
When 2 days pass,
how many bananas will they have left?
He will eat two more bananas,
there will be 96
What is the attitude?
It will be 96 to 2,
which is equal to 48.
It is clear that this attitude is not a constant.
It changed as we switched from one day to the next day.
We have no constant attitude
of the remaining bananas to the past days.
This is not a disproportionate dependency.
Things could have been different,
if it had been said whether the number of bananas Nate had eaten,
is directly proportional to the number of days that have passed?
Yes, of course, because
if this is the number
of the eaten bananas,
then it will always be 2 in number
of the days that have passed, so it will be 2
and then it will be 4,
and these relationships will always be 2.
But that's not what you are looking for.
We want to compare the number of other bananas
to the number of days passed.